we're game so I need a little bit
actually cash so we're gonna take a side
job clearing away some fish I'm Dave
joined by Tom or Hussein I hate fish
Donald fish you love fish Lucy James I
actually live near Billingsgate market I
really like fish and fish please Dave so
we are playing salmon run on splatoon
too if you don't notice the wave based
combat mode you shoot fish get eggs save
the eggs sure ash mode money salmon skin
roll so the love the difficulty level
goes from 5 percent to 100 percent we're
gonna start on about 10 I want to say
we've got a practice run so salmon run
like I said you need to kill bosses at
the end of each wave each boss will drop
an egg the eggs need to be placed into
an egg collection box and that's how you
Pat take it away you have to survive egg
box I'm a bucket boy splat shop junior
whole place so in this difficulty level
they all come from the same directions
so you still trying to force a joke son
Timmy you know a joke is like a five if
you need to force it it's probably [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's also true for love house the
images you just got a brush yeah I'm
just gonna brush this is like so you may
knows this is just my point of view just
mainly because no matter what a play is
spectacular
yeah yeah I mean grow up time get out
the emoji send me down something a loose
you're like Johnny
Oh Robert Moses gain side Baker go neck
if I get the egg people will fight the
other boss in a minute get the eggs oh
god I'm dead I'm bringing him home I'm
down okay who's coming home can you get
- I'm coming to your town no keep moving
no no you need to get the egg away we've
got a quota of four exits wave don't
worry
ah there we go big big lads dead gone to
the reg let's go oh I don't want to be a
melee weapon gaben aidid well I'm at the
quota but you know video game any
bonuses scary
that's right you'll be raised cover the
map anymore like free sex positions yeah
we always start from here you do have a
note if you push push in though and
white stick but you only get two per
game bazooka I'm a bucket boy
so you've got the eggs but what are you
what the things that come out of them
when they die they're just like points
you can use for currency I think points
me the guy prizes the guide of the fight
you know you need to shoot the balloon
on top of his head while he's growing it
me and Tom have rollies so we can't
actually do that so the balloon he's
blood he's expanding on his heads so you
need to focus the buzz will means how to
focus the mob oh I'm dead my range uh my
range is zero I have to Oh justice songs
from a bucket five eggs we got 42 more
so I can't get up the wall this way oh
there we go you know get older we'll pay
you money never - well a laser beam
right can fight the boss because we buy
eggs eggs in where's the boss he's the
guy with a big laser beam use your oh if
you need to oh there's lift nice work
Sam grab your eggs for years
Oh guys please get eggs fast well
extremely well also a bucket I think it
was a bad roll of weapons there who
needs two rollers you need two rollers
maybe we shouldn't do random all right
well this gives us an opportunity than
that why are we collecting eggs though
salmon salmon roe delicious grow up
wait no let's talk about like the sushi
uncultured swine sushi being cereal
I mean series great crisis so I think
the thing that I've done I've run out
cereal and then that's wrong
this guy you need to shoot from behind
he's in a bin he would have been in a
minute machine go sick pop Onegin
remember to use your oats if you need to
my mom lets me what is this I think I
think we've been led to the boss maybe
who was shooting me 45 seconds to do it
we've become distracted oh yeah I should
probably stop shooting Dave where's the
bus oh I just felt point there you go
all you need to throw a grenade in his
bin oh yeah
yes boy oh gosh I'm gonna get me up
please we need to get can't lose so
early get me up get me up coming up he
loves going egg just returned home with
it oh sorry we've done it we've met our
quota that was close though boys one you
can do about them green grenades going
to get raspy voice is he a bear
nice all right get some ink on the go
nice and pink too in the air because the
color clashing looks like one of those
bruiser bars
oh that the egg things moving it's on a
bin boy what is the point we need to go
to the fighters bin boy oh wow we saw
far away sorry help wise this brain
ciccolo a clue a clue
Oh oh my god oh it's raining green oh oh
you getting some busy shooting falls I'm
dead I'm holding I'm holding on the top
of his head top your head in a minute
I ask of you shut up with your hostility
doesn't make for a good team vision it's
on the John of bloody Beach who you went
the wrong way my shooter shooter shooter
said 20 seconds left
well shoot his head quick then gun well
well why are we so bad at this
we're so terrible it's actually quite
difficult
[Laughter]
my hours producers just shaken is that
don't think we'd ever see you
[Laughter]
third time's a charm code activate this
ice-cream van train is real cool I think
I think the RNG is depending on what
color you are stop
I mean you don't like pink so now orange
definitely win orange is cool orange is
the coolest color purple why is there so
many divisions within this team guys no
I just you know I'm losing right where's
where they coming from down here wait
wait out though ah ah ah stood here
they come from multiple directions just
saying being a sort of somebody delete
your like verbal filter explain word
association in real life
press up if you see the boss oops it's a
boy I was misled open your bin open your
bin yes lads
good wait why does my swimsuit come off
when I what what when you drown you just
you turn into a we've already met our
quota gasps now why'd you get a bonus
bonus eggs what's your favourite egg
dish day well you mean like favorite way
to eat an egg or like favorite thing
that has eggs in either my favorite way
to have an egg I like a good poached egg
yeah I do like a good scotch egg curry
pork I don't like the sound of a curry
you know mate it's great
naturally I'm gonna go for curry cuz
they were up the stereotype poached egg
poached egg on top of a English muffin I
have never had London days what's wrong
with you two I've heard nothing but bad
things about I mean I'm open to it
what's your favorite kind of egg what is
your favorite kind a baby my dude no for
Virts would you like an egg in this
trying time no that's a very good fish
where they at though I everything here
we go I'm just gonna Chuck loads of
bombs this boy have you ever thought we
could have salmon and poached egg and
then we dig up stupid I packed my brain
to think of something funny in it and it
did not fall through come on brain we
can do this not exist no longer working
please reset and try again
boom Oh
the snake is back oh don't this is an
evil version of Oscar boom God the eggs
easy money so many eggs too many egg 2 3
min ago when he's coming up in here
we need jokes
I appreciate it me thanks me it's a hot
gram reference to kiss levels very
orange big fan of that oh the bin man
there he is
where is it one I lost ever want to find
the bin man where's my mommy oh this is
gonna be a multi kill hello Oh sunshine
no no she looked me right in the eyes
and she said that I was weird yeah thank
you mrs. Meyers senator stone or I'm the
Cyclops from the Pennsylvania now you
just turn into boring when he would see
point O the noveria boys get out of the
green this this guy you have to shoot
from the bottom to the top
the baskets move me to the beach yeah
the baskets on the beach oh there's a
guy chasing me get the eggs where your
eggs up
this way oh oh oh not what you expect
I mean I expected a funny old nude lip
we smash that one I reckon I reckon just
for you know just for funsies we try a
much higher difficulty you see what
happens
oh it's gonna in much I'm up for it
we're gonna last like you know I feel
nervous
hold me ten seconds no of the difficulty
what do you always say an 80% 100%
eighty percent we can barely do ten oh
we did we justified did ten seventy on
the third attempt 60 quickly fifty boy
boy hundred twelve times is 180 look a
hundred Tamsin hundred professional I
like that that's good I'm singing the
same weapon I enjoyed this platen to
Wally's I reckon we could do it easy
it's only saying you know ten times
harder than what we just did
I can't see why we probably we're fine
okay I mean I'm ready and I start a
clock
how long do we last I'm Rick I reckon
like 30 seconds 30 seconds from the cat
from the countdown I give us like 15 15
yeah shoot your paint Lord everywhere
I baskets over here there's already a
bunch of green everywhere I say we stick
together yeah absolutely come in order
to stab each other in the back oh they
go this way okay stab each other in the
back Jimmy
Oh a third boss well boys are over oh
you did
I'm loaded fully Danny's I'm still alive
so give me a fam be GG that was around
penny seconds can we run a timer in that
place I'll put a clock on up on the Edit
well we beat one goal I guess and we do
it well yeah be a choir every single
time very fun on the other hand we
played four times yeah splatting is hot
I found that extremely exciting no pence
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video make sure you hit the
like button subscribe for more of our
dumb nonsense if you enjoyed splatoon -
let us know all that good stuff and
we'll see you again in the next daft
video that has 4 do tell me about your
favorite tell town about your favorite
eggs goodbye right soft-boiled a new
nickname